hello I'm Dolph Ziggler welcome to
@midnight
match plus I will be making a man bun of
my messy dress a secret to the perfect
man bun as first and foremost being the
perfect man so if you're not me
feel free to practice on Barbie dolls or
Ken dolls or anything that you can get
your hands on some shrubbery a man bun
says about your personality that you
don't care what anyone thinks in the 80s
so to make a bun first of all make sure
you have long horse's mane like locs and
then reach into your skinny jeans grab a
fancy rubber band that you can probably
get at H&M pull tight and if you're on
the west coast feel free to give
yourself that homemade facelift by
pulling tighter I'm 36 but I can play 29
because of this pull it straight wrap
around each finger twice wrap it around
one for those of you cardio guides and
for the body guys like me to I can get
it around make sure your skinny tie is
just a little askew you ready to do
up that has been @midnight master class
and I am don't sleep
great
[Music]